six beautiful some say handsome women
invited by the Academy not only to
present three awards but also to shatter
the common belief that size does not
matter I hate to tell you guys this but
it kind of does yes but not length as my
grandma used to say it can be short and
still make your toes curl and I believe
in my heart my grandma wasn't referring
to wieners but short films see I'd
rather have a short film with some heft
that's nice to me right rather than a
long film that just lies there and makes
you do all the work but sometimes the
film can be too long not for me not for
it here are the nominees for Best live
action short Pentecost Peter McDonald
and Emer okay Roger max gsella and
Stefan Gearin the shore Terry George and
Orla George time freak andrew bowler and
gigi Kazi tuba atlantic Calabar pizza
and the Oscar goes to the shore Terry
George and Orla George
this is the first Academy Award for
Terry George and his daughter
Orla George the shortest shot on
location in the bay in front of Terry
George's came in
by a cast and crew made up of friends
and family
thanks em this is my daughter the
producer I want to thank the Academy now
I don't have to wait for a wedding to
tell the world how brilliant she is our
little film was inspired by the people
of Northern Ireland Protestant and
Catholic who after 30 years of war sat
down negotiated a peace and proved to
the world that the Irish are great
talkers I want to dedicate this to them
and thank you again thank you very much
this is for you